we do have indeed Hikaru Hikaru first of
all the first word that comes to mind
when I see your match is effortless it
felt like that for us how did it feel
for you yeah I wouldn't say I was
effortless I think I played a pretty
pretty terrible game today
um you know I I basically want to
surprise Sam the opening by playing some
nonsense with his H6 move um I mean I
think the opening isn't that bad for
black but just the way that I followed
up was definitely not uh all that great
and I think somewhere in the middle game
was significantly worse
there was a tweet at this particular
moment uh Anish was asking which speed
run this is with H6 and A6 well I mean
but didn't um then Anish a second Irwin
let me play H6 with black or perhaps yes
I think he did but anyway
um no I mean A6 and B6 I think it's
relatively okay I don't think it's that
bad I mean maybe maybe I'm supposed to
take on C4 I don't know but I wasn't
really in the mood to do it so um yeah
that's life eight six what did Magnus
play I just saw the Magnus game pop up
because of course I mean I don't study
chess so I don't know these things yeah
what did Magnus play here uh let's see
Madam's played baseball he played B6
okay
ah because you can take with the queen
right away okay fairness yeah that makes
that makes more sense let's see if we
can get back to your game yeah so those
kind of kind of what I saw there
um but but anyway no I mean this is uh
yeah this is all maybe slightly better
for it probably I should have played C5
but just keep going like basically
somewhere around Queen B3 I played this
A5 move and already I'm starting to
drift a little bit and I think if Sam
had found this concept with Knight D2
and then some Bishop F3 maybe right here
maybe even later but at some moment in
the next like five moves if you found
this idea of going Knight two Bishop 3
and playing for E4 this would have been
very uh very scary for me but he didn't
do that I mean I just felt like it was a
little bit too tentative he wasn't 100
sure what to do and they played Rook A1
basically you know sing the boogeyman
for no reason because if he doesn't go
Rook A1 I mean again if he plays Knight
D2
rookie Bishop F3 I mean nobody cares
nobody cares about the queen side here
yeah oh the computer also all the
computer also doesn't care at all things
black is only a little bit worse which I
know to me is very surprising because it
just feels like E4 is coming in
somewhere here yep and it should be
scary like rookie one E4 some
combination but basically the point is
white has more space and so when Sam
trades the Rooks off this already helps
me so like just conceptually you
shouldn't be trading the Rooks so this
already I think it's a mistake that's
not to say white isn't still better but
I think it becomes much much harder to
come up with a straightforward plan I
mean for a computer it can just dilly
dally play random moves all over and
improve slowly but I mean for us at
least you you have to have a concrete
idea and once we trade trade the works
on A7 I don't think there was a concrete
idea and then Sam played 91 which I
think was just a bad move
um he just misunderstood the position
next move oh Knight three you wanting me
yeah he just misunderstood because see
Sam thought I had to play B5 and then he
was gonna go Knight D3 and go to E5 or
C5 which of course makes perfect sense
but I don't have to play B5 and then
once I go Knight E4 again less space so
obviously I want to trade pieces and if
he doesn't trade the knights I mean I
think already maybe black can even try
to claim an advantage somewhere so I
thought what he did was correct
um again I thought everything here was
very Bishop five I thought shows that
I'm kind of like in form because it's a
scary move to play if I'm wrong
um if I'm wrong I'm gonna just lose this
game but I can tell from the evalot
clearly I wasn't wrong so it worked out
and the rest of the game is just very
forcing and you spent a little bit of
time at this point calculating
everything after Queen to G5 did you
calculated all the way until the end
yeah I mean basically it went when uh
Sam was thinking or no when I was saying
about Bishop 5 I already saw this whole
position with Rook A1 and everything
else
um I mean I just assumed it was good
enough I didn't actually calculate all
the way to the end but I assumed with
the queen there had to be some way to to
save it and so that's sort of what I was
just calculating a second time and it
just I think everything was completely
forced I mean I think we basically
played this more or less perfectly
although I'm surprised to see it thinks
Queen F4 apparently
is good enough to draw too interesting
yeah interesting queen f41 queen to C1
yes I thought what I did was just much
more principled with Queen C1 and then
check and then yeah C5 to break the
break the structure and yeah there just
was nothing for either Queen C1 I also
saw but I'm Queen G2 with this uh this
symmetry moving the queen all over the
board on on the back ring the fifth
fifth row whatever you call that term I
found a way Hikaru you haven't played in
a very long time you were mentioning
that uh yesterday but now do you feel
like there's any rust left or do you
feel in shape I mean I I think uh I mean
I wouldn't say there's Russ I'm
obviously playing chess almost every day
but
um certainly I've survived the openings
and I figure if I survived the openings
then I have good chances against anybody
so we'll see if I can keep doing that
guys any questions our congratulations
uh well done and good luck and your next
round
thank you uh just turning to the game of
Naji and Anna Anna we know has been
playing on increments but